[Applaudissements]
dans 3 2 et l'épicerie ce domaine nous
sommes à trois rivières pour saluer nos
collègues de radio canada qui emménage
dans une toute nouvelle station on vous
présente donc et l'épicerie du marché du
vieux port au menu cette semaine que
manger les colons il ya 400 ans pourquoi
vous avez envie de vous déguiser et de
revivre l'époque de la nouvelle france
mais ma langue et comme vous êtes sao
paulo non vraiment madame vous manque du
tissu les gens l'air léo dallaire
assoyez vous confortablement nous allons
parcouru plus de 3000 km on s'arme en
estrie goûter de la lavande rose et de
la madeleine manger des charcuteries et
on s'en va cueillir des pêches en
ontario et tout ça du marché de la
petite nation en outaouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exxon et jeux de tes amis de tercica
[Musique]
du homard des tétines de souris et
d'autres produits de nouveaux produits
[Musique]
de la fromagerie du presbytère à sainte
élizabeth de warwick
cette semaine exceptionnellement on it à
vancouver est précisément aux marchés
publics de l'île granville
cette semaine nous avons pris le large
jusqu'en gaspésie au parc forillon le
chef jean claude roy nous concocte
classique les moules marinières vous
savez faire bouillir de lula
d'origine
juive nous allons suivre denis dans sa
lourde tâche est de sillonner les routes
pour trouver la meilleure tripe pas de
jalousie entre régions on se rend à
shawinigan en mauricie
et aux dires de jean chrétien lui même
la meilleure frites au monde se trouve
ici depuis 1942 la nourriture du hub
crevette nordique
spécialité de la côte-nord je vous ai
réservé une table avec vue sur la mer au
match point de vu sa cote dans
les numéros recensés
bonjour à vous cette semaine nous sommes
dans la belle région du kamouraska dans
le bas-saint-laurent le bas-du-fleuve
regorge de petits producteurs inventif
créatif qui nous proposent des produits
vraiment originaux il ya très longtemps
que le concept d'achat local existe dans
les villages autrefois ça s'appelait
acheter du voisin jorat nous amène dans
la région de charlevoix rencontre un
restaurateur qui perpétue cette
tradition qui aurait dit que le long du
fleuve saint laurent on pourrait se
faire une salade un mais selon heerd
maritimes se sont vraiment très bons
j'aurais voulu être mais nous sommes à
cinq ans de la période où ici depuis 75
ans sur la rivière sainte-anne des
milliers de personnes sans cabane
pourquoi pour taquiner le poulamon alors
pour célébrer l'été aujourd'hui
l'épicerie s'est arrêtée au terrain de
camping situé au pied du mont
saint-hilaire nous sommes dans la région
des mines les rivières les hautes
laurentides cette semaine nous sommes à
la ferme régis à notre dame des prairies
juste à côté de son marché by au menu on
déguste le délicieux pétoncles de débit
on est dans la merveilleuse région du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean nous sommes sur
le bord du majestueux lac témiscamingue
qui en fait c'est pas le québec de
l'ontario on ne peut pas trouver ce
sandwich à montréal halifax vraiment
notre seulement 1 toronto il dormir
comme des clans corrie pont saint
georges de beauce saint jacques de
montcalm mauvaise entre deux rives on
est sur le traversier entre québec et
lévis bonjour
la marche est tout va
merci
majestueuse rocheuses bienvenue
l'épicerie
[Musique]
on va aller chercher l'europe
avec une louche naturel et voilà
chaudhry le marais de ces pays
cette semaine nous avons la chance
d'être à l'île du prince édouard
aujourd'hui ce qu'on va découvrir c'est
la palombe géant on va la chercher sur
ce bateau au large de josh t cette
semaine nous sommes au brésil à rio plus
précisément de copenhague au danemark
les mêmes qui serait
le mieux